hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
umfangreichen mord review die gar nicht
umfangreich ist und das mit sarkasmus
war sondern die viel einfach eine tolle
sache hinzu die ich schon immer mal
vorstellen wollte aber noch nie einen
mord gefunden habt er das so wirklich
richtig gut hinzufügte dass es auch ein
bisschen funktioniert und zwar sieht es
hier schon momente da seht ihr es
dasteht dörte war steht es 8 so versteht
da steht also alle die englisch können
wissen das bedeutet auto und ich habe
hier so eine welt generiert bisher hier
sind überall schweine der dahinten
überall schwein ein fernes richtig krass
es ist der karl ott und der effekt
solche karls also autos hinzu und wir
die kräfte zeige ich euch jetzt mal eben
und zwar müsst ihr natürlich erstmal
reifen machen und den motor also engine
und reels wheels kräfte tier indem ihr
hier leder also acht leder um ein eisen
ihren also einen gott warum tut dann
bekommt ihr ein spiel davon braucht ihr
nachher 12 so und er braucht noch die
engine die macht in dem zwei pisten
links und rechts ab dann zwischen 1
redstone oben komplett frei darunter red
sox links redstone rechts und darunter
einen furness b 10 zwischen dann bekommt
ihr die engine davon braucht ihr nur ein
weil ein autor der nur ein motor aber
das ist dann auch wieder ein bisschen
komisch weil ein auto hat eigentlich
vier reifen
das hat auch vier weil man braucht nur
zwei wege so dass man wahrscheinlich
zwei reifen seinen egal jedenfalls baut
ihr euch das auto dann so in dem ihr
unten rechts reifen und links reifen
darin gott darin gott da oben die engine
drauf und da eine kiste und zwar was
also oben komplett frei
dann bekommt ihr das auto und jetzt
gleich bestimmten was alle mit der kiste
und zwar wenn ihr das auto hinsetzt
können jetzt erstmal nicht wegschieben
ihr könnt auf alles eigentlich drauf
setzen auf so gut wie alles halt auf
rost hat glaube ich nicht mit
rechtsklick seite da drin dann sieht das
ungefähr so aus ganz niedlich ich in
meinem kleinen tuff tuff auto sieht ein
bisschen komisch aus wenn man von der
seite das weil die füße dann so ein
bisschen
herausragend aber naja der mord deshalb
noch im aufbau jedenfalls setzt sich
halt jetzt was guckst du denn so das ist
ein ganz normales auto erst mal neue
ford fiesta oder vw scirocco den fingern
schön
dem würde ich mir glaube ich sogar bei
ca so jedenfalls wenn ihr in dem auto c
drückt seid ihr in dem carl inventory
und da praktisch alkohol oder ganz
normale kohle rein und dann kann das
auto fahren
hallo also rein tun sie funktionierten
das gar nicht also okay edit irgendwie
funktioniert das hier oben gerade nicht
jedenfalls haben wir jetzt den tank
aufgefüllt und nun können wir damit
fahren mit wie fahren wir vorwärts ist
egal wo ihr hinguckt mit das ist mit und
mit es fatal rückwärts und ihr steuert
das halt in dem wir nach links und
rechts fahrrad mit a und d also find ich
ganz gut egal wo ihr hinfahrt wurde sie
werden kann relativ schnell ihr vater
hat wirklich nur dahin wo eure tasten
hingehen wie schafft es auf zwei blöcke
hochzufahren
ich schaffte ein blog hochzufahren bei
zwei blöcken schafft es nicht mehr
behandelt auch so wie hochfahren da
komme ich jetzt zum beispiel nicht hoch
war was ich ganz witzig finde ihr könnt
damit echt hammer geschwindigkeit noch
wann welche schaut mal wie schnell ich
hier bin
um und tiere könnte damit übrigens nicht
verletzen
also es ist schon eine krasse
geschwindigkeit drauf war und ich zeig
mir was passiert wenn ihn wasserfahrt
momentchen man jetzt jetzt bin ich hier
gerade untergegangen sich und zwar fällt
das auto dann einfach auf dem grund vom
sehe da seht ihr es gerade jetzt wenn
ihr den welches grad nachts seht ihr es
hier könnt ihr dann ganz einfach wenn
ihr öfter darauf schlag habt es dann
wieder zur hand und die kohle fällt dann
auch wieder raus also dann könnte es
einfach wieder an land hinsetzen genauso
wie im echten leben wenn du da mit dem
auto ins wasser fährst dann auch einfach
auto abbauen wieder raus tragen und dann
wieder das benzin rein und zack ganze
weiterfahren
also ich kann jetzt hier dann kann ich
wieder zu drücken packe ich die alkohol
also das ist echt ein bisschen komisch
mit der jacko man weiß nie wo man die
insel honshu
wenn ich die jetzt so also das ist halt
noch ein bisschen der mod es noch also
jetzt wird es noch ein wenig magie und
die steuerung ist auch ein wenig komisch
als ihr seht ihr es noch ein wenig
ruckelig aber ich finde dass der mord
erst mal als nicht ganz gut funktioniert
kann man bestimmt noch mal ganz gut in
paretz place anwenden und so weiter und
so weiter
naja jedenfalls war es das erste mal von
der vorstellung download aus dem ort auf
jeden fall download link gibt es in der
beschreibung oder will ich sagen ich
stecke hier ein bisschen jetzt noch fest
das ist ja nicht mehr als zuschauer
probiert bin ich hier ja ich würde sagen
das war's für diese mod vorstellung ich
würde mich freuen wenn ihr dem video
einen daumen hoch gibt weil es war echt
witzig das system auszuprobieren
natürlich sagen provinz auf jeden fall
aus will diesmal schiesst ahn können
übrigens auch mods immer in die
kommentare schreiben